et là greg hill aux tonga guillotin vous
avez vu ça s'appelle le plan cul c'est
très simple il prend une photo avec sa
meuf et vous allez voir ce qui se passe
il est avec nous encore ce soir c'est la
deuxième partie vous aviez vu la
première partie la semaine dernière la
deuxième partie tout de suite c'est la
saison pas moins une petite photo de
nous merci beaucoup
parce qu'en fait on s'est rencontrés ici
[Musique]
excusez moi ce qui est appelé la croix
vous avez pas vu c'était qui c'est
françois c'était pour le travail qui
était qui monsieur françois monsieur
c'était qui j'ai pas vu françois loiron
le travail était sérieux quoi j'ai pas
mes françois monsieur c'est françois qui
appeler c'est françois
sur un contre un merci vous avez vu ah
non j'ai pas fait attention par contre
en q2
c'est un peuple
ses collègues non un collègue un
collègue sa collègue sa collecte ou des
photos d'hommes non non évidemment à bar
bulles
moi j'ai pu donner une fille en bikini 1
qui coule personnes
je veux juste vous dire que vous n'êtes
vraiment pas très honnête moi ça fait
trois fois que je me prépare exactement
la même chose que mademoiselle c'est
vraiment une honte si c'était lent qu'il
dise après gaulle et je me suis dit non
non je fais pareil pour marquer effacés
je ne l'étouffé bon ski noir et en fait
je crois que j'ai eu avec son téléphone
la ttc jean-claude vous avez loupé c'est
un club à la main est-ce que c'est un
collègue fois malgré vous me direz que
c'est vrai ouais c'est beaucoup
arrête toi dégâts
ici ce qui
c'est incorrect c'est monsieur il a fait
une tête bizarre j'ai vu que non c'est
pas j'ai pas fait une tête bizarre pour
ça c'est parce que regarder j'étais
obligée de fermer chaque cinq minutes
parce qu'il avait dit il ya que dix
secondes de batteries mois savoure à sa
juste part
merci monsieur ce gentil la serva
m